good afternoon I'm John Andrews
executive director of the Washington
branch of the English speaking union and
on behalf of everyone associated with
our organization I'd like to welcome you
to a very special occasion today we have
as our speaker a wonderful biographer in
fact she has been described by The
Sunday Times of London as one of
Britain's finest biographers and she is
going to be with us today to talk about
a new book called Elizabeth and Mary
it's a book about Queen Elizabeth the
first of England and Mary Queen of Scots
and it's it's a book whose narrative
flow is quite remarkable I was talking
with Jim Dunn a few minutes ago and was
suggesting to her that this really ought
to be a major motion picture so let's
let's hope that that merchants and ivory
are paying close attention before we
begin I wanted to say just a few words
of thanks first of all to our friends at
Alfred a Knopf and Random House for
making this occasion possible
they are the publishers for the us of
this wonderful new book and our friends
at Olsen's books and records who are
handling the book sales here in
Washington our friends at the Women's
National Democratic Club who are making
this facility this beautiful Club
available for us Jane Dunn is the author
not only of Elizabeth and Mary but of
several other biographies
she's probably best known for a book
about Virginia Woolf and Vanessa Bell
she is also the biographer of Mary
Shelley and of Antonio white she is
coming to us today or
she has come to us today from her home
in bath one of the most beautiful
settings in a beautiful country and we
are absolutely delighted that she has
made time out of her busy schedule to
share with us some thoughts about two of
the most fascinating women in British
history Jane well thank you John that's
a terrific home lead-up and it's always
enormous ly good fun for me to come to
America and I particularly love coming
in election year and there's so there's
so much I'd like to be asking you
actually about the cyclical battle for
power that you're now engaged in but I
have to talk to you instead about a
different struggle for power between as
John has as John has explained Elizabeth
the first of England and Mary Queen of
Scotland this is a fascinating story on
many levels it most simply it's the
story of the greatest rivalry one of the
compelling tragedies of our history and
for many of you with your English Irish
and Scottish ancestors it's your history
as much as mine but my book Elizabeth
and Mary is also about two very
different types of woman with opposing
attitudes towards queenship and their
own place in the world it's a contrast
in stars of leadership a contrast in
priorities as a female monarch was one a
queen first or a woman ordained by God
was one detached from the people or
ultimately dependent on their goodwill
the relationship between Elizabeth and
Mary fascinates us even now there are
regular phone poles in Great Britain
about who are the greatest Britons and
she is always in the top ten amongst
Churchill Shakespeare Darwin
whoever Elizabeth is always there and
there's no doubt mrs. Thatcher saw
herself as a modern Elizabeth and she
did she did and her rhetoric is is
slightly more clunking than Elizabeth's
but suddenly the Falklands campaign you
see was her own personal Armada against
the Spanish kept course the Portland's
against the Argentinians but that was
you know as good as the same but so this
relationship of the Queen's has
particular resonance in your election
year for Elizabeth and Mary make us
think about women and power as
autocratic queens they wielded more
power than even your president does of
you over the United States yet in the
running for president here and now in
this great democracy this land
opportunity and aspiration
where are your women this to an outsider
is such an interesting question because
we see American women as being the most
modern of women smashing through all
sorts of glass ceilings in industry and
business and the media but it seems the
top job is still closed and it makes me
wonder whether women aspiring to
ultimate power even 450 years later
whether they still have similar
prejudices to overcome as Elizabeth and
Mary had and do they have almost as much
to overcome in themselves to to really
believe that a woman is worthy to
compete for the ultimate prize without
conforming every aspect of herself to
the conventional hierarchies of power
let's see how Elizabeth the first and
Mary Queen of Scots fared with their
ambitions the story of the
interconnected lives is so full of drama
it would be unbelievable as fiction it
becomes a tragedy when both queens
threaten each other's lives and one ends
up
executing the other but it is this very
drama that has made these complex women
into caricature queens carrying the
passions and prejudices of centuries
Elizabeth as the cold calculating
Protestant virgin and and Mary as
anything from a sexy dimwit to a
murderess or a Catholic martyr but of
course they are much more complex and
interesting than that in the book I have
taken 1558 to be the pivotal year for
both these queens the point from which
their ambitions for their lives were
defined 1558 was the year mary 815
already Queen of Scotland married her
French prince the sickly boy who became
francis ii of france by becoming
fleetingly queen of france she fulfilled
all her family's highest ambitions and
set her course as a woman whose destiny
was linked to whom she married she was
young and she had conformed to what was
automatically expected of any young
princess that she make a dynastic
marriage and produced at least one son
and heir 15:58 was also the year when
Elizabeth aged 25
fulfilled her own personal ambitions and
succeeded at last to her father's throne
after a long and dangerous
apprenticeship she became what she had
always wanted to be queen of England but
from the start she had little interest
in fulfilling the next part of her
dynastic duty which was to marry a
prince and assure the succession she
considered herself instead to have
wedded her people in one of her first
speeches to Parliament she stretched out
her hand with a coronation ring upon her
married her marriage finger and she said
when I received this ring I solemnly
bound myself in marriage to the realm
and it will be quite sufficient for the
memorial of my name and my glory if
when I die an inscription be engraved
upon a marble tomb saying here lieth
Elizabeth which reigned a virgin and
died a virgin this was a revolutionary
decision all her schooling and she was a
very learned young woman pointed to the
intellectual and spiritual inferiority
of women the great classical authors she
and Mary both read and the biblical
texts which were the bedrock of her
Renaissance education asserted time and
again that it was unnatural dangerous
even to elevate women over men to give
them power was to court disaster if
through some misfortune a state should
end up with a female monarch as its head
at its head she must marry promptly and
acquire the necessary masculine hand on
the tiller of the great ship of state
and then of course everyone could relax
because it was in masculine hands again
despite all her Minister's efforts to
get her to marry the statement often
reiterated by Elizabeth that she was
disinclined to do so and instead had
made her contract with her Kingdom was
one of the great secrets of her success
she never underestimated the importance
of her popular following and she courted
it throughout her life she believed her
people loved her and in return she made
them believe that she loved them too by
remaining unmarried of course she risked
a messy succession she risked civil war
they feared should she unexpectedly die
but she never diluted the emotional
connection with her subjects she claimed
what were considered the masculine
virtues of courage and intellect while
casting herself in the female role of
mother and wife to her people
there are many eyewitness accounts of
her first entry into London as Queen and
they show this remarkable common touch
in a
one of them reads all her faculties were
in motion and every motion seemed a well
guided action her I was set upon one
person her ear listened to another her
judgment ran upon 1/3 to 1/4 she
addressed her speech her spirit seemed
to be everywhere and yet so entire in
herself as it seemed to be nowhere else
I think this shows that extraordinary
combination she had of absolute majesty
because here was an autocratic queen who
knew how to dress the part she dressed
to the nines she was extraordinarily
dramatic to see and yet in the and her
grandest processions her people would be
shouting out to her sometimes rippled
jokes Elizabeth had a very salty turn of
phrase and she would shout back in a way
that even our modern monarchy
today would absolutely never have that
sort of casualness and in carmalit ii
she was also very short-sighted and i
like to think if any of you have seen
someone you care for and short-sighted
how close they have to hold something
they're not wearing their glasses
there's a realtor poignancy and
tenderness about it and Elizabeth would
wheel her horse in the middle of these
grand processions if she was on
horseback she'd with her horse or if
she's in her carriage she had order her
her carriage driver over to somebody who
was holding out a little bunch of herbs
or a plea of books clemency or whatever
and she'd get really really close and so
I think for those people who saw this in
action this wonderful mixture of majesty
and intimacy you never forgot it it was
a very compelling combination
15:58 also saw the beginning of the
deadly rivalry between Elizabeth and
Mary a rivalry which would overtake them
both with the inexorable force of Greek
tragedy on Elizabeth's accession to the
throne
Mary's father-in-law henry ii of france
claimed the english and
Irish crowns as Mary's rightful
inheritance this was a direct challenge
to Elizabeth already insecure about her
own legitimacy for the Catholic powers
did not recognize Henry the eighth's
break with Rome his divorce from his
first Queen Catherine of Aragon and his
subsequent marriage to Anne Boleyn they
considered an to have been merely the
Kings [ __ ] and Elizabeth his bastard
child
they didn't mince matters in those days
Mary Queen of Scots on the other hand
could claim an unquestionable legitimacy
she was a great granddaughter of Henry
the seventh founder of the Tudor dynasty
this rival claimed to Elizabeth's throne
made concrete by her father-in-law and
continually asserted by Mary herself
right to her death propelled the tragedy
of their story the relationship between
these Queens was the most important of
their lives it was one relationship they
did not choose and could not escape even
in death it affected them politically
and personally blood cousins their
solidarity as rare female modern
monarchs was undermined by their rivalry
for the same throne and yet they never
met this was at the dramatic heart of
their story for a rival you never meet
grows in the imagination fueled by your
fantasies and fears and fed by the
stories of others in this way a rival
can become superhuman inhuman even and
therefore easier to kill by discussing
Elizabeth and Mary in relation to each
other
certain illuminating contrasts and
symmetries in their lives and natures
occur they were continually compared by
their ambassadors and were equally
fascinated themselves by each other
until scandal overtook her Mary was
considered the good tractable queen
while Elizabeth was contrary awkward and
resistant to conventional ideas of
womanly duty but the initiative kept
shifting between them later when
Elizabeth appeared to hold all the best
cards Mary could still play those she
had to devastating effect there is so
much in this book of the dynamic between
them but I can only give you two very
sketchy examples I'm afraid in the time
we have a great fundamental difference
between the queens was in the
experiences of childhood and early
adulthood and how this affected their
view of duty and personal happiness Mary
became this Queen of Scotland in 1542
when she was only six days old she never
knew any other condition and aware
always of her preeminence she was proud
of her status as Queen but sadly and
taking it for granted
she never truly valued what she had nor
realized it could be taken from her at
the age of six she was sent to France to
be brought up as a French princess at
the center of the richest and most
glamorous Court in Europe she was it's
beautiful cosseted star intelligent full
of energy and vivacity Mary could have
been educated to be the ruler she was
born to be but instead she was schooled
to be merely the charming accomplished
consort of a French king her Scottish
inheritance was barely valued beyond as
possible usefulness in providing the
back door for a French invasion of
England her early life and her brief
year as Queen of France was more about
pleasure and flattery courtly
accomplishments and grand expenditure
than statecraft
and self-discipline this lack of hard
experience was too fatally undermine her
when in 1561 she did return to Scotland
as a widow to rule her own people at
most inexperienced she was still only 18
we forget how young these people are and
in thrall to her powerful Nobles she
lacked the necessary authority and the
tools to assert her will she expected to
be loved and relied and had relied so
far on her extraordinary mixture of
beauty and charismatic charm to get her
what she needed she learnt too late the
lessons of kingship Elizabeth on the
other hand was neglected rather than
spoiled in a review in England Sirois
strong points out that Elizabeth is the
sort of Cinderella figure compared to
Mary's pampered princess in all this
Elizabeth had to endure great reversals
of fortune in her youth disinherited by
her father that's the old monster Henry
the eighth's of course and then
reinstated as one of his heirs again
before he died but even at the best of
times as a child she was only ever third
in line to the throne becoming Queen was
never a certainty during the white
rebellion in 1554 when Elizabeth was
only twenty years old she was imprisoned
in the terrifying Tower of London by her
sister this is Bloody Mary Mary the
first and under threat of death she had
learned very early how best to conduct
herself how much her fate was in her own
hands how unpredictable was life and
monarchy how much the support of the
people mattered isolated and disregarded
as a girl she decided that watchfulness
and equivocation was safer than
spontaneity and reckless action despite
the differences in their childhood
experiences both Elizabeth and Mary
Queen of Scots had remarkable mothers
who for different reasons were lost to
them history anyway is not good at
giving credit to the women to the
mothers an Berlin was an intellectual
woman
who had radical Protestant sympathies
she was courageous and spirited but she
was executed when Elizabeth was not yet
three and so was never known to her
daughter it is also dangerous but it was
also dangerous religious to be allied in
any way with a mother who'd been accused
of treason incest and witchcraft so
memory even was denied her in public it
was to her father's memory that
Elizabeth allied herself compared
herself and yet in private she showed
protectiveness towards her mother's name
and loyalty to her Berlin family there
exists a ring where there's a hidden
compartment which has a portrait of
Elizabeth and a portrait of her mother
face to face so it's nice to think that
she honored her mother if only in
private
similarly mary's mother was lost to her
to a French noblewoman Mary of geese was
her daughter's Regent in Scotland and as
an intelligent and redoubtable ruler was
an excellent role model model for her
daughter but sadly Mary and her mother
were separated and never really knew
each other for Mary of geese stayed on
in Scotland to safeguard her daughter's
inheritance and Mary growing up in
France pursued her dynastic destiny
there they only met one more time and
Mary never had a chance to see her
mother's careful rule she knew better
her mother's family in France the geese
her a band of charismatic and powerful
brothers very influential in court and
in Mary's life and in some respects
they're very like the young Kennedys
they were extremely glamorous they were
very tall actually much taller than the
Kennedys and they were perhaps the
Kennedys with knobs on because the
Dukakis was the eldest was a stupendous
military commander that even his enemies
thought was just brilliant and of course
the younger brother was the Cardinal of
Lorraine so they had church and army
tied up in gi's hands but these
glamorous uncle
reinforced her early experiences that
men were the executive force in a world
made for men probably the most
significant contrast between Elizabeth
and Mary came with their differing
responses to the challenge of having a
favorite accused of murder
Elizabeth faced this first only two
years into her reign she was at the
height of her love affair with Lord
Robert Dudley he later became the Earl
of Leicester and was possibly even
toying with the romance of marrying him
his young wife Amy Rob's art was found
dead at the bottom of a very short
flight of stairs her neck was broken
although Lord Robert was nowhere near
the scene of death at the time rumor
immediately implicated him with her
murder
he was already disliked for his
overweening ambition and his obvious
desire to marry the Queen
the scandal gathered so much force it
threatened to taint Elizabeth too
she recognized immediately that she
could not afford any shadow to fall on
her reputation as a popular but insecure
Queen she could not risk alienating her
people she banished Lord Robert to his
country estates she initiated the legal
inquiry which of course exonerated him
and he was quickly back in her favour
but she knew from that moment that her
people and her nobility would not allow
her to marry him even should she wish to
and were not certain that she
necessarily did although he was the love
of her life interestingly Mary faced
exactly the same dilemma but chose a
quite different course from which all
the calamities of her life then flowed
her second husband Lord Donnelly was
murdered in 1567 after her rapid
marriage to him had rapidly turned sour
the man who seemed to dominate her
affections at the time
Earl of Bothwell was also the main
suspect in the Kings murder there was
immediate popular outrage against them
both Elizabeth seemed to be less
exercised as to whether her cousin was
guilty or not of complicity in her
husband's murder but she did care
passionately about Mary's reputation and
by association the fragile reputation of
all Queens
Rickett recognizing the danger of her
cousin situation she she writes the most
urgent sisterly letter of advice and she
writes in French because of course that
was Mary's natural language bind by now
and she didn't want her to miss any
nuance Madame she writes my ears have
been so deafened and my understanding so
grieved and my heart so affrighted to
hear the dreadful news of the abominable
murder of your mad husband and my killed
cousin she's referring of course to Don
Lee who was a cousin both to Elizabeth
and to Mary but it's I think wonderful
that he's you're mad husband and my
killed cousin that I scarcely have the
Wits to write about it I exhort you I
counsel you and I beseech you to take
this thing so much to heart that you
will not fear to touch even him whom you
have nearest to you she means both well
that no persuasion will prevent you from
making an example out of this to the
whole world that you are both a noble
princess and a loyal wife Mary was
outraged she should be so patronized by
this elder cousin and but both of them
knew that the world was watching and I
mean by the world I mean Europe it was
Mary's tragedy that she not only ignored
this good advice but she defiantly
married the man after a show trial had
done nothing more than stoke the fury
against them posters in the streets of
Edinburgh denounced Bothwell as a
murderer and
marry in the guise of a mermaid as his
[ __ ] the threat of Civil War her
resultant imprisonment forced abdication
escape and exile all followed from this
folly but throughout her life Mary was
capable of great physical courage and
adventurousness that amazed even her
contemporaries even the tough old Scots
when her blood was up she was game for
any enterprise and was much more
impetuously bellicose than Elizabeth on
more than one occasion she rode with her
men booted and spurred like them some
said in male clothing and with a pistol
tucked into her saddle she was also
recklessly emotional in her judgments
even in her first miserable imprisonment
in the middle of Loch Leven Mary refused
to denounce both well reported as
declaring she will live and die with him
if it were put to her choice she would
leave her Kingdom and dignity to live as
a simple Demoiselle with him and that
she will never consent that he shall
fare worse or have more harm than
herself to a romantic and modern
sensibility this is an admirable
sentiment but to a pragmatist like
Elizabeth who passionately believed that
a queen was elevated to her preeminent
role by God and owed her crown every
care such reckless disregard with for
her position and sacred duty was
contemptible Mary's eventual escape from
Loch Leven brought her to England to
Fleet England instead of to France
was another of her disastrous emotional
decisions it placed both her and
Elizabeth in an impossible situation
there began the last long and dangerous
act of the tragedy of these two queens
Mary's seventeen years of confinement in
various northern castles turned into as
much of a bondage for Elizabeth as it
was for her prisoner
I am NOT free Elizabeth said on one
occasion I am a captive to Mary had
desperately sought refuge and help from
Elizabeth to reclaim her Scottish throne
but Elizabeth could neither forced the
Scottish Lords to take her back as Queen
nor could she allow her to go into exile
in France her claim on Elizabeth's
throne was too powerful to give her
freedom of action in such hostile
territory and yet Elizabeth knew that
there was something oppressive and
illegal in keeping her fellow Queen
prisoner
however duplicitous Elizabeth may be it
mattered to her that she at least it
appeared to be honorable and above all
just Mary's prodigious energies now
became focused on dreams of rescue and
plots for escape she also spent quite a
lot of time doing very aggressive
embroidery if any of you have seen some
of it its emblems which showed Elizabeth
in very bad light either as extremely
crossed
tabby cat playing with a mouse which was
meant to be Mary or a wonderful pillow
that she embroiders for the Duke of
Norfolk when she's hoping he's going to
marry her and spring her to freedom in
one of the many plots where she's got a
vine that has a two branches one is
fruitful and one is barren and she
embroiders this hand with a pruning
sickle cutting off the barren the barren
vine so obviously exhorting Norfolk to
go and do his duty and destroy Elizabeth
and put the fruitful Mary in her place
these plots increasingly involve the
dispatch even the destruction of
Elizabeth and the replacement of the
Protestant Queen with the Catholic Mary
on her English throne mary became the
focus for any discontent at home and for
foreign interests hostile to Elizabeth
abroad as the English Queen's life
seemed increasingly imperiled she was
under mounting pressure begged by her
Lords to do away with this troublesome
prisoner there it's really interesting
there are at least two occasions when
they write that the lords have tears
coursing down the
cheeks as they big Elizabeth to do
something and they obviously concern for
her life and obviously concerned also
for themselves and the state of square
but it makes me think that before the
Victorians got their dread hand on the
English character we were a much more
expressive Bunch than than we're allowed
to be by by legend now but only with
incontrovertible proof could they
persuade Elizabeth to act when Sir
Francis Walsingham set a trap for Mary
she lept into it with both feet in what
became known as the Babington plot the
last great plot of her career
the letters between Mary and a young
Catholic zealot Anthony Babington were
intercepted and deciphered the invasion
of England by Spain the uprising of
disaffected English Catholics their
sassa nation of Elizabeth and
installation of Mary as the next Queen
of England was all part of the lurid
plan that Mary enthusiastically endorsed
while out stag hunting with her jailer
Mary saw a group of horsemen come over
the brow of a distant Hill her heart
lept here were the long-promised
conspirators who would spring her to
freedom at last her despair and fear on
realizing that instead they were
Elizabeth's commissioners come to arrest
her on the capital charge of treason
marked the low point from which she
would arise set on Redemption she was
not to show any real public dismay again
Mary never accepted any responsibility
or knowledge even of the plots against
Elizabeth's throne or life she
maintained her claim that she was
persecuted for her religion alone she
had determined that she would die not as
a conspirator in treason but as a martyr
for her faith she conducted herself
throughout the trial with haughty
composure she and Elizabeth were locked
in a battle for the moral high ground
she defended herself with great
intelligence and assured
and received her sentence of death with
an ecstatic expression a contemporary
described her lifting her hands and eyes
up to heaven and giving God thanks for
it
rejoicing in her heart that she was
taken to be an instrument for the
re-establishing of religion in these
islands this disconcerted and enraged
Elizabeth who was struggling herself
with a terrible responsibility of having
to sign her cousin's death warrant she
feared the morality of it of a queen
killing a fellow Queen even more she
feared the political consequences
England was still an impoverished small
nation surrounded by the much more
powerful and prosperous Catholic powers
of Spain and France
what vengeance would be unleashed by
this act of regicide Elizabeth feared
she might even lose Scotland's precious
neutrality on her vulnerable northern
border to the French ambassador who had
come to plead for clemency
elizabeth burst out with it is
impossible to save my own life if I
preserve that of the Queen of Scots but
if you ambassadors can point out any
means whereby I may do it consistent
with my own security I shall be greatly
obliged to you never having shed so many
tears at the death of my father of my
brother King Edward of my sister Mary as
I have done for this unfortunate affair
the relationship now had its own
momentum that meant that for one Queen
to live the other had to die it was Mary
who went to her death in the dark cold
month of February 1587 she was 44 she
conducted herself with nobility and a
terrific sense of theater by insisting
she was a martyr not a traitor
she not only rescued her reputation from
the wreckage of her life she quickly
entered the realms of sainthood and
mythology as her star shot heaven woods
Elizabeth's plummeted
in guilt and fear the English queen
turned on her immediate ministers and
accused them of having tricked her into
signing the death warrant she blamed
everyone she ranted and railed and
threatened with imprisonment banishment
even death then she slipped into a
melancholic depression Mary's death was
the nadya of Elizabeth's life but it
also became the means by which she rose
phoenix-like
to become our greatest Queen Elizabeth
as Gloriana the catalyst for this
transformation was the long feared
aggression of Spain during the previous
years the Spanish had been deleted
diligently amassing their great Amada
now with Mary's death philip ii was
propelled at last into vengeful action
against England the following summer of
1588 a great Spanish fleet was heading
for the coast intent on invasion an
eyewitness report of the magnificent and
terrifying sight is so eloquent and such
a brilliant example I think of the best
of Elizabethan prose that I thought had
read your tiny bit of it
the Amada consisted of a hundred and
thirty ships and called by the arrogant
name of invincible the galleons with
lofty turrets like castles were spread
out before us in a crescent spreading
for about seven miles they were sailing
very slowly there with full sails the
winds being as it were tired with
carrying them and the ocean groaning
under the weight of them it's such a
brilliant image of those top-heavy
massive boats and the slow progress they
made because they were so heavy
in fact the weather good luck small fast
English ships and cheeky seamanship
managed to disperse this great threat
Elizabeth was asked by Lord Robert
Dudley now the Earl of Leicester to
address the troops who were waiting to
repel any invaders at Tilbury which is
near the mouth of the Thames and of
course the Thames was the great river
that would lead them straight up to
London and the heart of power she wrote
among her men wearing a breastplate of
Steel it was said some said it was gold
perhaps there was no breastplate at all
but that is how they saw their warrior
queen here she gave the greatest speech
of her life and it's one of the most
compelling speeches in English language
in England we grew up with it and I'm
sure many of you know it but it's a
tiniest bit again that I can give you
because of time but it's some it's
rather again rather wonderful
Elizabethan prose my loving people she
began let tyrants fear I have so behaved
myself that under God I have placed my
chieftess strength and safeguard in the
loyal hearts and goodwill of my subjects
she is calling in all those years of
loyalty from Queen to people and people
to Queen where for I am come among you
at this time but for my recreation and
pleasure being resolved in the midst and
heat of battle to live and die amongst
you all to lay down for my God and for
my kingdom and for my people mine honor
and my blood even in the dust I know I
have the body of a weak and feeble woman
but I have the heart and stomach of a
king and a king of England too now she
had no speech writers she had no spin
doctors but she was brilliant at
propaganda and her best speeches were
pretty quickly printed and distributed
and it's nice to think that perhaps
Shakespeare who was starting out in his
career might have read one of those
crumpled puts a paper in the dust and
been inspired so the Transfiguration of
both Queens was complete through the
tragedy of her death mary had become the
noble and saintly queen and thereby I
raised the shadows of the murder of her
husband the loss of her son the
discarding of her Kingdom the complicity
in treason against her
Queen and by and by becoming a warrior
Queen Elizabeth managed to cast off the
habit of her two-faced indecision and
the trauma of having killed a fellow
queen through action she had transformed
herself into the great monarch she had
always wanted to be at Elizabeth's own
death in 1603 400 years ago the contrary
ambitions of these two remarkable queens
were united at last with the accession
to Elizabeth's precious throne of Mary's
son James the six of Scotland as James
the first of England he ruled over a
United and Protestant Great Britain
representing both Stuart and Tudor
ideals
Thank You Jane for a truly eloquent
presentation I hope everyone who had the
opportunity to hear these remarks will
now go out and buy the book because this
is just a taste of what the book has to
offer I'm also delighted I was
acknowledging a number of people as we
began the program I forgot to mention
that this program is being shared with
the national audience through c-span I
only wish that the people watching this
program on c-span have the opportunity
as they often do on c-span programs to
call in with their questions
unfortunately that will not be the case
but I'm sure there are plenty of good
questions in the audience we have here
today yes John why France wasn't more
heavily involved in the defense of Mary
it's it's really interesting she
absolutely lost all support in France
over the whole debacle of the Darnley
murder and her lack of judicious action
over both well don't forget also
catherine de medici was then really in
Parmenio son who was it was King but she
she had become at last after all those
years of waiting
she had come into her own and Catherine
was never a fan of Mary's they both the
Spanish and papacy and the and the the
French monarchy had were very shocked by
the whole terrible carrying on in in
Edinburgh during that murder of Don Lee
and running off with Botsford Boswell
episode and it was only Elizabeth
interestingly who supported Mary
Elizabeth was particularly outraged that
a populous could rise up against their
monarch she saw this as outrageous thing
to to to have happen and of course it
threatened her
own insecure position to some extent
because if if people could think that
they could get rid of their their queen
or king then that could happen to her
too
but you're absolutely right it is
surprising that she was very much
abandoned by the Catholic powers at that
time yeah the ultimate legacy in her new
to me the ingrained believe in English
Exceptionalist that is superior in all
faiths and governance to the constant
well when she first came to the throne
England was very impoverished of Henry's
Wars had abroad had been Wars of
aggrandizement where he's trying to sort
of live up to the Magnificent Francis
the first of France who he was a very
very he was almost a twin actually
within age this is part of Elizabeth's
horror of war was seeing just the
depredation of the country and of the
coffers that war involved then of course
there was the absolute sort of Cataclysm
of Edwards extreme Protestantism ed with
the sick who inherited after Henry the
eighth's
and then Mary switching the whole
country around back into very fanatic
Catholicism with philip ii of spain sort
of or the spanish driving that
particular switch
so when Elizabeth's reign started this
was a pretty to moralize little country
but the years she allowed of peace
allowed for prosperity and this growing
sense of self and ant nation hood as
well as a real flowering of creative
energy because if you're going to war
all the time your energies are being
dispersed your young men are being
killed this was just a most wonderful
period for them to have decades of peace
and that's when the great Renaissance
flowering of Elizabethan culture
adventurism piracy could could happen so
it was really only as her reign
progressed I think that there was this
very strong sense of how to be English
was to be best
sorry my process Hamrick natural pushing
the blood very unencumbered
what is now very good yes didn't marry
not intend to spark a rebellion and it
is that meet out any punishment to
marriage supporters me
initially the I think Mary was still so
much expecting Elizabeth to welcome her
with open arms because in Lizabeth
because of Elizabeth's support of her
during the uprising of her Nobles
against her Mary had been lulled into
this sense of solidarity without
realizing because she in sense lacked a
political sense she didn't realize that
her presence in on English soil was
actually a terrible catch-22 for
Elizabeth so in it Mary was still
agitating like mad to meet Elizabeth and
they nearly met at York but it also it
all started really relatively amicably
and was only as the rain progressed that
increasing disaffection amongst English
Catholics started to focus on this
extremely poignant and appealing image
of the sort of wrongly imprisoned Queen
when I say imprisoned of course was more
a house arrest most of the time she had
her court she was able to go hunting she
was able and unless there was any
uprising in the country in which case
she was more closely contained but no
there was no there was no punishment of
her supporters at that point it just
became as the rain progressed more
perilous for Elizabeth's life and that's
when some of the more draconian laws
came in against practicing Catholicism
openly and priests who were coming in
from the continent would be turned back
or imprisoned and in extreme cases
tortured
you've written about a variety of women
how do you choose the topic of your
biography and also looking at the craft
of writing how much time do you spend
researching for the first writing mobile
well those are marvelous questions and I
could go on forever you're absolutely
right the choosing of the topic is so
important because it is like a marriage
in a sense you are living with these
people for years on end and so you need
to be able to keep your interest alive
for all that period of time I the this
pairing of women is one of the most
fascinating relationships of women and I
am interested in in women's
relationships my one of my previous
books was about Vanessa Bell and
Virginia Woolf er the sisters and that I
see I see this book as a sort of
progression out of that one as for how
long one spends researching and writing
you could spend your lifetime
researching and this is the real problem
is that there comes that point where you
have to say I need to start writing and
that's always the most scary part of it
so I would say this book took me about
five years probably three of that was
researched but then the research goes on
while you're writing as well because you
don't know till the whole thing starts
to unfold quite where you want it to go
it has a life of its own - you can't
know it absolutely how you're going to
impose your patterns on it although you
know pretty clearly when you start so
it's it's a long process and it is a
sort of it does take a dedicated sort of
affection to do it I seem to recall when
I was in Westminster Abbey that Mary's
two
that's right and I was surprised suppose
she would be entitled to it for a number
of reasons acquit James's mother actors
and children to say but how did how did
that happen it took a long time to get
there and it was
you're quite right it was James who who
made that beautiful to when she lies
side by side with with Mary with
Elizabeth she yes she was she was
initially they were so frightened when
they executed her about the sort of
force I think that many go very shocked
by what happened and the force of
emotion around this whole episode that
all remnants of her were removed quickly
and she was buried at Fotheringay they
scrubbed every splash of blood and got
rid of every piece of furniture and
cloth that had been used in the whole
process because they didn't want it to
become a sort of relic and therefore to
fuel this martyrdom and this mythology
she then in in it was dug up and
reburied and initially at Peterborough
and then was brought down by James and
and and given this proper beautiful -
yes and quite rightly side-by-side I
think because oh oh in my life I wasn't
following visions about
seven how much input was very ill for
time how much input does he have in that
selection and what's that selection
inevitable missus of gems James that the
the six Hooper big who yes who inherits
it she became reconcile turd I'm and and
in fact was in quite a lot of
correspondence with James towards the
end of her life and he'd certainly been
groomed for it
and he was the obvious choice and he was
a man and it was in perhaps perhaps it
was also a sort of sort of something
just about it also that he was marries
Mary's son and he was a tutor and a
steward I mean he's he'd come down
through the the tutor line as well
although the direct one from Henry the
eighth's had died out with Elizabeth but
he was he was he was schooled for it and
it was inevitable but you're quite right
she resisted naming a successor all her
life because she had been so horrified
by what had happened during her sister
Mary the first string when disaffection
for Mary had had sort of focused on
Elizabeth and as Mary Lay Dying the
courtiers lepton their horses and
galloped down the road to Hatfield to be
there when Elizabeth was proclaimed
Queen and that always horrified her and
she always felt that's not something she
wanted to happen to her you were you
were talking about the imprisonment of
Mary
Elizabeth's reaction to that in a way
that suggests that Elizabeth was almost
a prisoner as well under relationship
could you talk just a bit more about
that well III think that Mary coming
into England really was the last thing
that Elizabeth wanted and it was an
impossible situation she she tried to
send her back to Scotland but this but
the Scottish Lords had absolutely no
intention of taking her back as Queen
and unless Elizabeth were going to do it
with force there was no way she could
get Mary back on the Scottish throne
which is what Mary wanted she also as I
said could not possibly let her go to
France which would be a natural home for
her she loved her French relations and
all her life sort of thought of France I
think as the the certainly the country
of her use the country of her happiness
but this she would not give up this
claim and it's a powerful claim because
the whole of Catholic Europe which is
most eclectic Europe rightly saw her as
the legitimate heir and Elizabeth as an
illegitimate so she couldn't let her go
with this fantastic claim in her pocket
into such hostile territory as France so
Elizabeth was in a very difficult
situation and it was a sort of bondage
- it's absolutely right she made it
worse hmm
and I'm amazed that you could treat
various sympathetic says you to it well
I think I think if you understand her
character in a way you realize that she
was not a reflective person she was not
somebody who looked ahead at the
consequences of her actions or looked
back she lived in the present she was a
woman who lived by her feelings and by
her senses and so adventure was
necessary for her you know she was
always expressing herself outwardly she
would Elizabeth imprisoned her in for 18
years would become the greatest scholar
of the Renaissance because she was a
much more introverted personality in a
sense Mary it drove her mad because she
needed to be this extrovert expressive
person and so it's almost inevitable
that she will it get involved in any
madcap scheme that comes away because
that's where her energy has to go so
that's how I felt for her we're seeing
that in a way with her nature how could
she be peaceful or submissive or
compromised her her claim in any way
yeah so that she was accused of treason
murder on witchcraft as long as there
was any my new public record of the
trial is it for me Abilene Abilene was a
fuse of witchcraft Mary no sat me
oh yes the records of Mary's trial exist
and and they are very impressive and
she's very impressive in it she she she
shows a real grasp of her status her
situation no it was an Berlin which was
a terrible trumped-up charges of incest
with her brother and with all sorts of
men of the court and witchcraft which of
course was a terrible taint and it
tainted Elizabeth because the child of a
witch had a real black mark against her
so that's really why in many respects
Elizabeth never mentioned her mother's
name in public yes
she was the child of the marriage that
was supposed to propagate a vanity to
their mind it elicited Elizabeth ever
cool like personal satisfaction like
kind of benches mothers trumped up
charges and execution person it's so
hard to tell because she really does not
mention her mother at all I think there
was real satisfaction that she became
such a much-loved queen I think that she
very much reinforces us in so many of
her speeches and you saw it in their
modest speech where she's sort of you
know she says it your loyalty my loyalty
here we are together it's bits it's a
huge mystery about her feelings about
her mother and I think the ring actually
is all that we have that actually shows
that she had a very warm spot for her
but never expressed not in public anyway
yes she must've felt when the Sun really
was a treasure
oh not Mary sir James yes absolutely no
she was she was furious she was furious
but of course James had never known his
own mother I mean he he was aristocratic
and and noble families didn't really
bring their children up in close
proximity with their mothers because
mothers had to go on breeding and said
they were quickly given to the wet nurse
breasts were bound up back into the
breeding program again and James was
quickly sent away and then of course his
mother was imprisoned and had to
abdicate and he was made King of
Scotland before he was two years old and
from then on he was brought up by the
Protestant Lords strictly Protestant
well-schooled to be the sort of King
they wanted and quite quickly he was a
clever man he realized in his teens that
he was much better off allowing himself
with Elizabeth than with Mary she was
outraged angry resentful and vengeful
what I found so surprising was that her
will when she died left her rights to
the English throne antis and an to
Scotland even though she had been forced
to abdicate to the Spanish unless James
became a Catholic and that I think was a
sort of no it's it's really it's a quite
remarkable thing but the the paper
exists and of course she had no power to
do this but it was a sort of moral and
emotional slap or a modernist slap to
her son so it's um she didn't she didn't
forgive that
one point I'm spoken about is the Whaley
totally different situation of the true
Queens and the way they have all the
churches in their respective realms Mary
as are called
lost complete control of the be Scottish
Presbyterian Church whereas in this
fifth Catholic Church and being on a
fairly tight rein when they vote they
both actually were extremely tolerant
religiously I mean they both obviously
Mary was a Catholic she was born and
bred a Catholic she was not a fanatic in
any respect
she was relatively devout but not even
excessively so except in Midland
middle-aged and quite understandably
given that she was imprisoned and and
was facing death
Elizabeth similarly Elizabeth actually
was probably much more conservative than
what she was certainly more conservative
from religious point of view than her
ministers who were distinctly Protestant
she probably was still as most of her
country actually an old-fashioned
Catholic because you don't quickly
switch a whole people around but she
very much knew that presentism was the
coming religion and that this was state
religion and she didn't mind what people
did as long as they kept the right face
only in the latter part of her reign
when it really was getting dangerous did
some of the more draconian laws come in
against practicing Catholicism openly
and priests coming in and trying to
convert and so they both were actually
extremely tolerant and you're right Mary
had to be because she had an external
she had a much more radical Protestant
nobility she also had John Knox who was
one of the most amazingly powerful
orator and he would weekly her rang her
and use the most abusive language about
her and her and her religion and she she
was reduced to tears by this man at
times I mean he was he was like taking a
scouring sort of pad to a took two to
two ones ones heart but a magnificent
and orator and proponent of his extreme
brand of Protestantism
so they were basically tolerant women